my name pretty much welcome back to
amnesia electromagnetic pulses have
knocked out the electrical system so
don't worry bro if I'm going down that
you are going down with me brother all
right I have an aide well I can jump
with it
I have an ood I can jump wizard I have
an aide dumping with I can't wait I am
standing in front of you that is why
whoa there's one Edward told me okay
do it don't whatever would we got this
don't worry I'm gonna quick say because
you know Edward you got a nice butt
Edward I don't know I don't why don't
you go and check it wait I'll stay close
I am saying right behind you brother all
right
oh no not again
I didn't see it god dammit
they are sneaky there's sneaky and he'll
oh well I quicksave I really don't have
any [ __ ] animal
I have a [ __ ] nade that's all I got
I can't even find it I'm 16
can i charges or some it's gonna explode
in my house what you have a problem with
me being mad [ __ ] [ __ ] staring at
my buddy I don't know why there's
problem all right so we can charge it it
takes explodes I thought it was like you
hold them thing I don't know when I got
don't worry ed stay close all right
I did stay alive would be a better
suggestion I'm just sayin all right he
comes there right nope not today sir
did I kill it this is so bad for me stop
no can't stop won't sup I'm a pilling in
my pit can we do something about that
thing don't know what when your new
stuff take it how it hurt me - I have to
[ __ ] hell oh okay okay we got Emma
all right and let's go
helps would be [ __ ] fantastic
go ahead you [ __ ] where comes another
where old man I don't like this where is
it weather
when what what what what ah well
political that was not close he [ __ ]
got me it's not fair they one-shot me
what the [ __ ] am I supposed to do
alright whatever at least it's saved in
a good spot
I just [ __ ] go there right away
so ed doesn't take wet wet [ __ ] you I
have one half I have one day
yeah I won help I have one health I have
one pill
no yes yeah I would say no not another
one I have one [ __ ] hell I have one
[ __ ] hell one [ __ ] have
[ __ ] got one [ __ ] here is
that bubbling [ __ ] oh please yes yes we
have health we won't get one shattered
anyway let's go [ __ ]
why did I do that I'm such a oh sorry
all right I'm sorry oh it's not that
easy
it's not that easy all right I'm camping
man UN shoot it in there
Edie Edie Edie don't play games with me
and we need you oh no all right we're
almost there anyway all right cool I'm
sorry ad you were - bro I didn't know
all right cool we can chief 39 I'm just
gonna guess
all right where do we go ah oh my god
what a weird Quinn you said it well
Stephen got a lot creepier I'm not gonna
lie
okay I got oh oh come to Papa yeah we me
gusta how do I get out of here
I [ __ ] I shut can we go in here I don't
know if I want to go in here
one of it what what is that I saw
something
hello
Reuben is that you I will get I think
but probably not for long it spiders oh
I hate spiders
[ __ ] all right let's get more spiders
Morris fine
come on alright [ __ ] they're betting oh
[ __ ] me
no spiders bats fighter bad fighter
that's fight it don't fight it get up oh
stop fighting - fighting [ __ ] no more
what is this what is this ah come on
Dima spiders not good for me
ha ha ha yes yeah yeah oh thank god ah
[ __ ] you stop stop it's not funny
anymore
ha stop stop stop stop
up and up and help and open open open
open open open up and open yes [ __ ]
did it
that's how I roll that's how I get
Donnelly this I don't get they keep
saying that
amen good times let's go have a
girlfriend I guess I don't want a lady
all right follow Rubin ah those
fireballs I'm not gonna work on me man
[ __ ] you got a gun uhh
stupid [ __ ] oh no come closer
ha ha ha ha barrels are right here with
me oh this is a parallel universe
surprise badass and barrels aren't
working with me what what the [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] kick in my face with that
what is this
yeah no no god double no triple brick go
sniff enough is this shut up
alright uh uh spiders should not be able
to know how to open doors
ah let me read the [ __ ] PDA holy [ __ ]
this is Operations Coordinator mark
Lambie
that's how I roll okay I don't know
where HR is getting the new employees
but the last five guys they've sent me
were all a bunch of idiots
yes they can't use any of their work
done on time I constantly have to keep
an eye on them they work slow they don't
follow any of the standard operating
procedure complain uh change the cabinet
door code solution one two three hours I
thought that was easy enough to remember
tax me still for goalies hahahahaha then
why HR can't get me better people in
order to to hire and fire my own
employees
I can run my department smoothly fact
they probably got someone like me
working for them one two three it's a
password alright that sounds a [ __ ] it
don't even remember what what what ah Oh
bender hey it's like one of those games
but we're back haha what why don't you
shoot it bet it's use it my fists
that's what she said okay oh we can only
go uh-huh
uh-huh is it going back and forth I
can't tell I think this is good oh oh
sorry
cuz no no no you're doing it wrong
okay down yes Oh your mom barrel whoops
wrong one
come here barrel no you catch me back up
all right all right that should be it go
down man oh this should be perfect yes
ha ha and now we okay up we put you down
ha ha you oh sorry too much excitement
and then died ha ha
[ __ ] is there not a better way to do
this this is gonna take me quite a while
I stopped punching the controls man
let's try it with a close one instead
close one come in baron
so knowing I can't watch words going all
right I think forget it yeah we got it
come here little [ __ ] it's probably
better to go this way and then stop
punching the contract and then follower
so slow - what the [ __ ] and then maybe
lower it so we make sure that it
actually goes in I can't lower it that
means it's gotta be right right yeah all
right cool
it's good this one while we're at it
toxic gas levels decreased 50% yeah all
right so we only need one more then grab
at a [ __ ] I suck at these games I was
taken away one barrel oh wait there's
only two open that means I only have to
get that one and we're done okay good
what how it's impossible it fell over
no no does he do you have to do that I'm
not telling you to go up you know this
game is so annoying
I hate these games oh we got it we got
it nailed it
come on yes [ __ ] yes that's how I roll
yay hi you good man well hurry you gotta
pick up the pace
I need an arrow uh you go down okay
that's what you get when you don't clean
come it cleany whoa are you going
cleaning cleaning I feel like there's
probably something here that I should do
what I swear to god engine Jack come
here pity oh well I guess can yay Oh
number 47 oh yeah that's the one two
three one ha ha ha I don't even remember
it all right all right cool
we got a bunch of stuff let's go down to
funky town
no well the way the [ __ ] do you want to
go then maybe it's not this room okay
this room actually I'm two chambers push
it I can really enjoying this kind of
home road today and I'll see you next
episode of whatever on me stay on some
roads my activate
well I can fine that's okay I have a
girlfriend anyway why not buddy [ __ ] not
why did I know I don't get